cooley koro about an hour's drive from
the Malian capital Bamako the European
training mission is based here at a
Malian army camp 40 instructors and 40
medical personnel from Germany are part
of the European force on a recent visit
the german defence minister said it was
essential to contain the Islamists in
the north thus daughter and a bit they
pose a threat to the entire Sahel region
molly is just one border away from the
Mediterranean so it's in the European
interest to stop terrorism from
spreading in Mali in Milan is plotted
the European mission will provide
training for some 4,000 Malian troops in
Brussels they're keen to stress this is
not a combat mission and its duration is
limited but it might take longer than
planned their plan is of comfortable the
European Union's plan is set at 15
months the Malians are also determined
to keep it as short as possible but
whether 15 months will be long enough
we'll just have to see what progress is
made we not how to tear our focus the
Malian government is hoping the European
mission will deliver fast results
Szczepanski are three coulombs I believe
it will allow our security forces to
work more quickly and effectively in
recapturing and securing territory and
pave the way for negotiations talks with
opposition groups are another initiative
being pushed by the european union
wisconsin was thailand this all needs to
be part of a political process of
reconciliation of madame noire with the
north as well as within the various
groups across the country and other
aspect is elections which should take
place in July Germany will be the second
biggest contributor to the European
mission behind France with up to 330
soldiers it's also sent an air tanker
for refueling missions and three cargo
planes stationed in neighboring Senegal
no wonder